what I am as an academic who realize
that you can't do academics inside of
the University system watch it
disintegrated to Madness as we speak I
figured this out a long time ago I want
to know whether this is right or wrong
so much better so much more that I want
to know whether UFOs exist UFOs to me
are an indication of whether I'm right
or wrong
you see it's data it's an input to me
because so if you're right that means
if we have a future it means we can
leave not the planet but the solar
system we can explore the cosmos are
traversable
if we can leave anything else can visit
if you look at the entirety of the
universe and you imagines that
ultimately there are societies that
destroy themselves because they get
Atomic weapons before they figure out
how to leave
some societies are smarter
and they'll be able to leave and and
colonize the cosmos and for them not to
be here would be Madness